so let me set out five specific things
which the government will need to be
satisfied of before we will consider it
safe to adjust any of the current
measures first we must protect the NHS
his ability to cope we must be confident
that we're able to provide sufficient
critical care and specialist treatment
right across the UK the NH staff have
been incredible we must continue to
support them as much as we can
second we need to see a sustained and
consistent fall in the daily death rates
from coronavirus so we're confident that
we've moved beyond the peak third we
need to have reliable data from Sage
showing that the rate of infection is
decreasing to manageable levels across
the board fourth we need to be confident
that the range of operational challenges
including testing capacity and PPE are
in hand with supply able to meet future
demand fifth and this is really crucial
we must be confident that any
adjustments to the current measures will
not risk a second peak of infections
that overwhelm the NHS the worst thing
that we could do right now is to ease up
to soon allow a second peak of the virus
to hit the NHS and hit the British
people it will be the worst outcome not
just for public health but for the
economy for our country as a whole